hey we partnered up with a company
called dreamworld to bring you exclusive
anime merch that you can't find anywhere
else if you love demon Sayer we've got
conjured off my boy sided soup and so
much more check it out at enter
dreamworld com
or click the link in the description
what up space fam goes in here from
anime out Pro and today we're going to
be talking about the official end of
demon slayer and everything we know so
far about the demon slayer movie
including the latest updates if you
enjoy seeing demon slayer videos on this
channel and want to keep them coming
show the demons there's some love by
smashing that like button and sharing
this video we cover a lot of anime on
this channel and it's always fun to see
what the fan base is favorite anime is
and one way we can judge that is by
number of likes so if demons there is
one of your favorites
be sure to absolutely destroy that like
button let's see if we can get something
epic like over 10,000 likes if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial ring that notification bell or
you will miss future Demon Slayer videos
and updates to get early access to our
updates and reviews follow our podcast
anime out Pro audio on Spotify Apple
podcasts or wherever else you listen to
podcasts links in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
first off let's talk about the news we
have about the end of the Demon Slayer
manga series multiple articles online
from Mickey calm to comic book calm have
been reporting that chapter 205 of the
manga which is supposed to drop on May
17th will be the official end of the
demon slayer manga and that doesn't mean
that we won't get any more demon see
related stuff like sequels or spin-offs
since that might still happen especially
considering the popularity of Demon
Slayer more on that later but as far as
this Demon Slayer series that we know
set in a specific time with specific
characters that's gonna come to an end
although some characters may return as
older versions of themselves if you
recall the end of chapter 204 showed us
a modern landscape suggesting that a lot
of time has passed and the new and final
chapter will take place in this setting
this in my mind is the perfect setup for
a new series that will take place in the
demons
world but where our main characters have
to fight demons in the modern age with
all of the uniqueness and complications
that that brings but let me know your
thoughts are you sad at the demons their
manga series we knew is no more are you
looking forward to demon slaying in the
modern age or are you upset by this turn
of events let me know in the comment I
personally think that chapter 204 was a
beautiful end to a great story and I'm
open-minded to see where we go from here
besides we also have many more epic
moments some of my favorites that had
yet to be animated so we'll be able to
look forward to that in the upcoming
years and that brings me to the new
Demon Slayer movie and it's surprising
that I haven't done a video yet about
this movie since it's huge and obviously
I cover Demon Slayer on this channel in
regards to movie if you somehow don't
know yet after the first Demon Slayer
season a demon serie movie was announced
this is not like when some anime do a
bonus side movie in between cannon
seasons and by cannon I just mean
content from the actual manga rather
than an original non canon or sometimes
called filler content in this case we're
getting something I haven't seen often
the demon serie movie will actually
continue with manga material right where
season 1 left off so in a way this movie
is gonna be like a short season - one of
the reasons they're probably doing this
is because Demon Slayer is insanely
popular in 2019 so for that year Demon
Slayer has a series sold more manga than
any other manga including one piece 2020
will be even crazier the reporting year
for manga sales is from November to
October and as of May 13th 2020 the
demon seer manga reportedly sold at
least 40 million copies for this year
making it one of the best selling years
for any manga series already with plenty
of the reporting year left to go that's
absolutely insane and I think that the
movie which will likely have a very nice
budget is gonna be capitalizing on this
popularity which as we've seen has only
increased in 2020 the fact that the
movie is also canon makes it impossible
for fans of the anime to ignore when you
consider that non-canon one piece movies
can gross crazy figures approaching 100
million dollars worldwide then you can
imagine
how much a can and movie for the
currently best-selling manga of the year
can make
I'm not saying that this movie will beat
the one-piece movies but I am personally
excited to see how many fans this movie
is gonna draw in and whether it's gonna
become one of the highest-grossing
animated films of all time in my view it
definitely has the potential to break
into the top 50 so when's the movie
being released as of now the film is
scheduled to release in Japanese
theaters on October 16th 2020 so not
only is the movie going to be fueled by
the record-breaking sales of the demon
slayer manga this year the buzz around
the film is also sure to increase the
sales of the manga as well
now I'll quickly refer to the likely
plot that will take place in this film
so if your anime only and don't want to
know you can click off the video right
now three-two-one okay so for people who
are wondering how much exactly the movie
will cover it seems clear to me that it
is going to be covering the fight
between lower moon one the strongest
slower moon and our main characters on
the demon train lower moon one and moves
abilities allow him to enter or let his
servants enter other people's dreams
once in their dreams and mu or his
servants can find and destroy their
spiritual core which will destroy the
mind of the opponent we're going to get
some epicness from the flame pillar
georgiou roaring Goku one of my favorite
characters in anime the dango ku is so
inspirational I posted not one but two
quotes of him on my anime upper
Instagram link in the description one of
them goes like this no matter how weak
or unworthy you feel keep your heart
burning grit your teeth and move forward
if you just curl up in a ball and hide
time will pass by it won't stop for you
while you wallow in grief and quote
that's the kind of stuff you can expect
from Kyoto rain Goku he'll remind you to
set your heart ablaze and most
importantly to always smash that like
button however I think that the movie
will end before then Goku really gets to
shine it has brightest level and we'll
have to wait until the next movie or
season to see him in his full glory
after the defeat of lower Moon one-upper
moon three Icaza shows up the best
villain in demon serum
I view and an all-around very strong
demon dude 10:07 suan eNOS K won't stand
a chance against this guy so then Goku
will have to fight him this is going to
be an epic fight one of my favorites but
I think that this movie will end right
as Icaza shows up thus building more
hype around the next season lower moon
one has definitely been presented as
being the main bad guy for this film so
it makes sense that it will end after
his defeat and that is it for this quick
update video on the demon seer manga the
film and demon slayers mind-blowing
popularity if you want to see more of
these kinds of update videos let me know
by smashing that like button and sharing
this video we cover a lot of anime on
this channel and it's always fun to see
what the fan bases favorite anime is in
one way we can judge that is by number
of likes so if demons there is one of
your favorites
be sure to absolutely destroy that like
button let's see if we can get something
epic like over 10,000 likes also leave a
comment letting me know if you get value
from these kinds of videos as well if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell or you will
miss new Demon Slayer videos and
important updates and let me know what
specific Demon Slayer videos you are
itching to see to get early access to
our updates and reviews follow our
podcast anime opera audio on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever else you
listen to podcasts links in the
description lastly the YouTube ad rates
have significantly dropped recently so
the help and support we're getting from
our anime up for patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who helped us survive these YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible first and foremost I
want to thank the legend acknowledged by
Lorde we go himself after an A and the
one tier patrons the ones who stay on
top all clans Stephen and Radha a Lola
an autumn the world stealers Tyson
Kirino acquire respect potato Jonathan
King deci d brandon of aisles and
emperor otaku and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius Anatole kazansky angel Cruz I
Sparky 65 cricket
XP Ted no Ted Jo Stanton very Gucci
Alicia actor in Amal 69 jessica calif on
he no commie and water bonnie park saudi
are 12 row two and a hora pn huang mitch
loves anime cynical and JCC waka thank
you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
an Amir or and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to a
private patron only discord where we
talked about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the youtube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you